[موسيقى]
مرحبا الجمهور في الوطن العربي وحتى
النقاد لما تسالهم ما هو العمل الرمضاني
المفضل لديك ستجد حائرا ما بين عده اعمال
لن تجد بينها مسلسل خليجي ولذلك لابد ان
نسال لماذا لا زالت تهره الاعمال الخليجيه
داخل المنطقه فقط
هناك سببين اول شيء هناك سبب
اللهجه والطباع فنقدر نقول هناك حاجز ما
بين المشاهد العربي
والدراما او الاعمال الخليجيه وفي جانب
وفي جانب اخر هو ضعف هذه الاعمال سواء من
احد الكتابه او من ناحيه الاداءات
التمثيليه يعني لما نشوف مثلا مسلسل
محافظه مسامير وهو مسلسل يعرض على نتفليكس
مع ذلك مشاهد بشكل كبير عربيا وشاهد ولا
انا على شخصي قبلت العديد من الجماهير من
او الصحافه ممن تتعاطى مع هذا المسلسل
وتتفاعل معه على الرغم وجود هذا الحاجز
ما يقولوا لصنع هذه الاعمال اللي قد تكون
مرضيه له كمشاهد محلي يطمح لان تطير هذه
المسلسلات خارج حدود المنافسه المحليه
يحتاج المشاهد العربي لكي تصل اليه
الدراما الخليجيه بشكل عام والدرامه
السعوديه بشكل خاص
التسويق الاعلانات اكثر
نشر العديد من
الاعلانات عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لان ما كل متلقي في دول الدول العرب
يستطيع ان يجلس امام التلفزيون والله اذا
بيوصلوني يعني على مشاهده عالميه اكون
يعني يبثون اكثر يعني كاعلانات
وكرشادات بره على المسلسلات العربيه بحيث
انها تنتشر للمسلسلات الخليجيه ومن برا
يبو فكره او يدخلوا
السياحه حقتهم هناك او يدخلوا اي معلومات
عن بلدهم يشدهم انهم يشاهدون اكثر او
يضيفوا ممثلين من هذه المناطق يكون يعني
هم
المشاهدين هناك يحبوا يتابعوهم قضايا اللي
داخل الاسره اللي في قضايا في نفس المجتمع
عشان تكون بصوره اوضح يعني لهم على اساس
انه يتابعونها اكثر
[موسيقى]
بمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات